the slumbering giant that is America has
finally awakened chips is now at the
very heart of U.S China tensions
technological leadership has been the
source of U.S strength since World War
II we shouldn't be dependent on any one
port any one country any one Island an
economic competition that is manageable
could turn into something bigger and
hotter and unmanageable
[Music]
um
American manufacturing the backbone of
our economy began to get hollowed out
companies move jobs overseas today we're
down to producing only around 10 percent
of the world's chips despite leading the
world in research and design of new chip
Technologies
but folks where is it written where is
it written that America can't lead the
world once again in manufacturing it's
hard to think of a component in any
product really that's more ubiquitous
and more essential than the
semiconductor today almost any device
with an on off switch has one or often
dozens or hundreds of semiconductors
inside they power our cars airplanes
trains Communications rely on them
factories ordinary businesses and
finance and Banks money moves thanks to
these chips U.S no longer manufactures
the most Innovative chips seven
nanometers or below Taiwan manufactures
92 percent of those chips eight percent
of those chips were manufactured in
South Korea and none are manufactured in
in the U.S we just want more of the new
manufacturing that's coming online to
happen in the U.S there was a sense that
globalization is inevitable we should
offshore these jobs no big deal if the
Rust Belt is hollowed out
that decision is is one of the reasons
that the U.S elected Donald Trump and
that is why Joe Biden is pushing
industrial strategy and that is why we
are at a pendulum shift in the political
economy not just in the U.S but in many
developed countries when people think
about industrial policy it has been a
bit of a dirty word in the U.S politic
and hey free market should Reign this is
not like any other industry this is so
critical for the future and I think
that's why you know it really deserves
somewhat unique attention from an
industrial policy perspective
the Congress
privilege and
it's to present to you the president of
the United States we're going to make
sure the supply chain for America begins
in America that's why
that's why we came together to pass the
bipartisan chips and science Act
this is really the crowning Jewel in in
the Biden policy Crown so what's behind
the chips Act is an attempt to protect
the economic security of the US far into
the future the whole chips Act is 52.7
billion dollars 39 billion is for Grants
there's also an investment tax credit on
top of this which gives a 25 tax credit
off of any Fab that's constructed or or
improved upon the focus of the chips Act
is on producing the chips that the U.S
needs for its National Security
requirements Department of Defense the
intelligence agencies and the associated
companies are going to build products
for them as the U.S looks to become a a
real leader in global chip making again
it's looking at creating centers across
the country where it can build up on on
the skills both of the people and and of
the local suppliers that can that are
needed around these large chip Fabs
these are fabrication plots these are
the big factories and they produce the
Wafers like large discs of silicon
on which chips are printed and then cut
so this is really at the heart of all
chip making and these plants cost tens
of billions of dollars you have some of
the largest industrial projects that
have ever been undertaken and they're
building the smallest things that have
ever been built on Earth and if we get
there we have good transistors and a
good cost structure we're going to win
Foundry customers and Manufacturing will
shift back to the US today the Rust Belt
ends today the Silicon Heartland begins
[Music]
is one of five U.S Workforce hubs
focused on manufacturing jobs
[Music]
it is really an exciting day to be here
and this Builds on 40 years that Intel
has been in Arizona
we put our chips on the table right with
this investment now we're going to put
our shovels in the ground and get this
thing underway and we are excited for
the opportunity to expand and now have
over 50 billion dollars of invested
capital in the state of Arizona Arizona
has been a center of semiconductor
Manufacturing in the U.S for several
decades but in the past couple of years
it's seen major new Investments both
from Intel and from tsmc both of which
are building brand new Cutting Edge chip
making facilities
Advanced manufacturing has been an
incredible industry for Arizona and part
of the reason I'm so focused in on it as
mayor is I feel that it'll develop a
healthier economy more diverse and that
so much of the future of the world's
technologies will need chips which are
going to be made here in Phoenix the
chips Act is going to change Phoenix
forever
we have seen unemployment rates change
and we're also working on the workforce
side and we were recently selected by
the White House as one of five Workforce
hubs
I'm very focused on trying to create a
knowledge-based economy with high-wage
jobs that's why I'm betting on the
semiconductor industry Arizona State
University has been a key partner in our
semiconductor expansion
the rate at which the technology is
moving that is the smallness of the
features right you hear about three
nanometers you hear about two nanometer
this is coming okay and those are really
pushing the boundaries of what physics
will allow well how do we solve that
problem that gets an engineering student
excited engineering and these students
they want to solve problems
foreign
[Applause]
I was really interested into working in
semiconductor industry I chose Material
Science because Material Science is
something that people in the industry
are looking for I'm interested to be an
inventor and making technology in a
specific area inventing new materials to
like improve the chips trying to make an
impact on our society
now I feel like I'm getting very close
to that dream so this is our clean room
and we have a lot of tools but you could
notice one of the things you would start
noticing right away
this area is wide that area is yellow
and again coming back to like when you
do the any sort of lithography work when
you're exposing like a film and you're
developing it you want to have like no
UV light
the U.S doesn't have all the talent to
staff these Fabs you're going to need
about 27
000 people with fairly High technical
skills over the next five to ten years
because we're going to need thousands of
people from outside the U.S with the
right skills which means we're going to
have to facilitate the immigration of
these people U.S like has like such a
environment where you can succeed if you
want to if you really strive for
something you can achieve it and that's
what attracts me in U.S I didn't feel
the same way back in my country Talent
is a big challenge we need to overcome
there's then there's two sides of it one
we need to work harder on stem education
that's one side of the coin and that's
going to fix the medium and and long
term the short term we need to have some
modifications to our immigration policy
which is very very broken for high
skilled immigration if you look at the
founding of Silicon Valley there were uh
workers from Europe from Korea from
Egypt for example in the founding of
some of the earliest companies in
Silicon Valley it's an area of concern
it's an area of priority and the chips
act and funding some of that skills
development but at the same time I look
at this and the response that we've
gotten for instance from University
system in the U.S you know at the
community college level at the
University level you know the top tier
schools has been phenomenal
[Music]
Intel is one of the most underrated
stories in the tech industry and that's
a big thing to say given how prominent
it's been and everybody knows the brand
but what I don't think people appreciate
is that for about half a century this
company was the complete leader in an
entire industry it invented integrated
circuits which are the what we think of
as microprocessors as chips and it
basically LED that industry in
manufacturing for a half a century and
what that meant was that with each new
generation of chips it designed it also
developed the manufacturing processes to
build them and it was developing things
that were smaller and faster than
anybody else could design and it was it
was typically two to three years or even
more ahead of the entire Global chip
industry but what's happened more
recently is a different story in the
last five to eight years Intel lost its
Edge it lost its ability T to just keep
staying one step ahead of the rivals if
you like and other companies caught up
the plan that I've laid out for Intel
says that we'll invest about 30 billion
in capital per year for five years
150 billion dollars these are
extraordinary Investments and when you
go look at those of you know tsmc or
Samsung you know they're similar we've
been declining for 30 years can we start
inclining for the next 30 Years
foreign
[Music]
here is a world where material is grown
into crystals with controlled impurities
with intolerances which are molecular
even atomic
the objective semiconductors transistors
and diodes needed by the millions so at
the very beginning of the chip age
Gordon Moore who was one of the founders
of intel was looking for a way to
explain to people how chips were going
to be in everything how Electronics the
whole world of electronics was about to
go through a revolution that nobody
could quite understand in 1965 Gordon
Moore set out in a paper what became
known as Moore's Law the idea behind it
was that the number of transistors per
chip would double every year or two and
that was just a prediction it's not a
law of nature but it's proven correct
for over half a century the basic goal
whatever the product
make it smaller more reliable more
economical extend its function if you go
to the store and buy a new smartphone
just the primary semiconductor on the
phone will have 10 or 20 billion tiny
transistors carved into the silicon and
each one of those transistors is so
small it's roughly the size of a
coronavirus and there's no device that
we've produced at such vast scale using
such microscopic components
now as transistors get smaller and
smaller it's getting harder than ever
before to shrink them further major
companies like Intel or tsmc they've
outlined very clear Pathways to keep
Moore's Law alive for years to come till
the periodic table is exhausted Moore's
Law isn't finished right we're just
gonna you know keep bending the edge of
science to find you know how to keep
these advancements underway for the
future of AI for the future of all sorts
of technological advances it's
absolutely critical that we keep this
rate of innovation happening as rapidly
as possible for many years into the
future trips have been at the center of
electronics and Computing from the very
beginning and it's been very easy to
ignore them they're just there we take
them for granted but all that's changed
we've all discovered during the pandemic
that an interruption of Chip supplies
can affect everything can affect all
manufacturing Industries so suddenly the
chip world is being turned on its head
and Intel in the all-purpose chip world
is really trying to rethink it's wrong
six million Vehicles were taken out of
production plans in 2021 due to the
semiconductor shortage
over the course of 2021 and 2022 car
companies globally saw several hundred
billion dollars in Lost sales because
they couldn't get the chips they needed
to finish their cars car lines shut down
just because there weren't enough chips
available car makers cut their purchases
of chips thinking they would sell fewer
cars and so all the chip makers instead
sold to PC companies and then suddenly
there was a whiplash how do we de-risk
how do we make sure that we have
multiple suppliers so that we aren't
reliant on a single supplier and how do
we make sure there's enough capacity in
the supply chain today 90 of the world's
most advanced processors the types of
chips in your smartphone or PC or in
data centers and telecoms
infrastructures can only be produced by
tsmc which has all of its most advanced
production in Taiwan in 1990 we
manufactured 37 of semiconductors here
on U.S Shores now we manufacture 12
percent and falling over concentration
in manufacturing in East Asia is neither
good for our national security or
Economic Security
tsmc the global leader at the moment
basically focuses on most of its
manufacturing close to its home and
operates
absolutely massive plants with huge
output when the company was founded in
1987 it had a really unique business
model it would only manufacture ships
not design any in-house and that
business model let it serve a wide
variety of customers companies like
apple or Nvidia and as a result it's
grown far larger than any other chip
maker of its kind and because of its
scale it's been able to drive down costs
but also hone its technology because for
every silicon wafer it produces it
gathers data hones its production
processes and so it's not a coincidence
that tsmc is both the world's largest
ship maker it's also the world's
Advanced chip maker should we have 92
percent of all semiconductors in Taiwan
maybe not such a good idea that's an
incredible vulnerability and it really
makes you stop and think how did we get
to a place where countries and companies
thought that this was okay you know I
think a lot about what would happen in
this country around the world if there
were to be a blockade of Taiwan if there
were to be a hot war in the South China
Seas the only near-term comparison we
have to something like this is the war
in Ukraine that created a global market
event we had inflation you know we had
huge Corrections we had you know both in
companies and countries an interruption
of the supply chains not just in ships
but in everything through the South
China Seas would be a thousand times
that this is a bad day for president XI
and the Chinese Communist Party
the slumbering giant that is America has
finally awakened to the challenge that
we Face from
the People's Republic of China their
aggressive posture in the region
and the potential they would have of
cutting off our access to Advanced
semiconductors
predictable Chinese drills around Taiwan
this morning simulating sealing off this
self-governed island Taiwan says dozens
of Chinese warplanes once again crossed
the very sensitive de facto Maritime
border of the Taiwan Strait over the
past decade Chinese military power in
the Taiwan Straits has grown
dramatically as China's ramped up its
military spending and focused almost all
of its military efforts on threatening
Taiwan
foreign
[Music]
imagine what would happen today if
instead of an oil embargo like we had in
the 1970s there was a chip embargo if
the economy collapses and if there are
large interruptions in in everyday life
and the functioning of society you could
essentially expect production lines
across the world to just start the
global Paradigm is changing and that
creates bumps and that can create
conflict and there is a real risk at
this moment that an economic competition
that is manageable could turn into
something bigger and hotter and
unmanageable and that really does worry
me what if China in some way got control
of Taiwan it doesn't have to be an
invasion but a much lower budget
approach would be to make sure that the
right folks won the next Taiwanese
election and what happens if the
Taiwanese government says to the U.S
thanks a lot you can go now conflict
need not be military conflict and that's
a point it gets lost we have a chance to
manage that conflict using things like
export controls using things like
industrial policy but conflict is
inevitable and that's where the
semiconductor
industry and the chips act come in in
the tension that's emerged between the
U.S and China the Computing industry in
the tech industry is at the heart of
future Global competitiveness and
National Security and in that Tech
rivalry that's emerged chips are right
at the center the U.S has realized that
it's China's lack of a real skill in
making Advanced chips that is the only
thing that's holding it back from
becoming an advanced technology power
and so the US is actively acting to stop
China gaining that chip technology it's
not in our interest
to provide technology to China that
could be used against us
and at a time when it's engaged in a
buildup of its nuclear weapons program
in a very opaque way
today China is a relatively minor player
in the chip industry China spends as
much money each year importing
semiconductors and suspends importing
oil and China has to buy all these
semiconductors from abroad because it's
domestic capabilities at The Cutting
Edge are quite Limited in addition to
the 25 to 30 percent it consumes you
know it has another 25 to 30 percent of
world supply chain goes through China so
it plays a critical role in the supply
chain as well in 2014 Chinese president
Xi Jinping identified semiconductors as
a core technology that China should
produce domestically and since that
point china has poured tens of billions
of dollars a year roughly one ships act
a year into subsidizing its own domestic
production
foreign
industry has become like a symbol of
whether China can build its own
self-reliance technology industry at the
center of the government-led investment
it's the national integrated circuits
fund known as the big fund so big funds
have been raising
340 billion Renminbi which is 47 billion
dollar since 2014 and so far with lots
of fruits from such a big investment so
Beijing have to basically rethink
whether this is such an approach it's
useful in aggregate Chinese chip
industry still lags behind
technologically despite all these
generous subsidies and when you look
across the supply chain China is years
behind The Cutting Edge in Taiwan Korea
or other countries the big shift that
we're seeing is more of a bifurcation
between the China Focus chip industry
and the chip industry selling to the
rest of the world it's not just the
basic science that has to be groked but
there's a lot of tests nowatives if you
wish shop floor knowledge into how to
make it work that's very hard to
replicate tsmc has a tremendous amount
of shop floor knowledge that tacit
knowledge of their workers of how to
make those processes actually run and
produce high yields
the U.S is considering tightening curbs
on the export of chips to China Advanced
semiconductors a key development and
National Security priority in China
um
foreign
and we see competition not conflict
investing in our alliances
and working with our allies to protect
Advanced Technologies so they will not
be used against us
[Music]
the chip world is now moving into
specialized chips for specialized
purposes in AI that means gpus a
different type of Chip that was
originally designed for gaming but has
now been repurposed for AI
and we've seen Nvidia which is really
leads the world in gpus
become the world's most valuable chip
company and indeed hit a trillion dollar
valuation just on the strength of these
single purpose chips that work well in
AI it used to be that emerging
Technologies especially in the United
States came out of the Department of
Defense think of it Satellite Systems in
general semiconductors themselves but
also things like radar sonar GPS that
now we can't live without but because
they came out of the National Security
Enterprise of the government
you had a chance for them to diffuse
slowly into civilian life and the US
government could manage whatever risk
they had of their adversaries using the
same technology today there are a bunch
of Technologies Artificial Intelligence
being just one of them where the lead of
this is actually happening in the
private sector and the US government is
trying to catch up and as the government
appreciates what the National Security
implications of these Technologies are
how does it now try to put rabbits back
in the box or manage the risks that
these technologies have to the National
Security competing with China requires
everyone on the field operating as a
whole of government and working in a
bipartisan way with Congress it requires
the use of the full extent of our
economic diplomatic and Military Tools
in 2022 the U.S imposed new restrictions
on the transfer of certain ships used to
train artificial intelligence systems to
China today almost all of the world's
Advanced AI chips are designed by U.S
firms and manufactured in Taiwan and
data centers in China that were training
AI systems were using these ships as
well and the US wants to limit China's
access to these high-end ships with the
aim of constraining China's ability to
deploy AI systems for defense and
intelligence use cases technological
leadership has been the source of U.S
strength since World War II and that was
when the US discovered that if you have
the most advanced technology you could
make your own security you could achieve
leadership in the world and a lot of
what's happened since then has been an
effort to keep America's technological
Supremacy the U.S and China have been
doing a supply chain dance for a couple
of decades maybe four decades now
sometimes it's gone well other times
it's been more dysfunctional and I think
we're really kind of nearing a zero day
where we begin to understand okay we
can't have the status quo anymore and
what are Supply chains globally going to
look like
foreign
[Music]